el proyecto de integración de europa es
un proyecto siempre frágil siempre en
construcción y no hay garantías para que
este proceso siga siempre adelante puede
en cualquier momento pararse o dejar de
existir está amenazado y en esto en este
tiempo de amenaza del proyecto
comunitario en alemania conecta la
cabeza ha sido un garante diríamos de
soluciones pragmáticas de compromiso que
permitiese en salvar la esencia al menos
de ese proyecto
eso al mismo tiempo pues significa tener
que hacer compromisos con
países en los cuales
los derechos fundamentales tal y como
están recogidos en los primeros
artículos del tratado de la unión
europea pues no sólo se garantizan con
la misma pureza que en alemania estamos
hablando de hungría o de polonia la
división de los poderes en el mismo
tribunal de justicia de la europea ha
hablado y al respecto
por tanto es una manera de ver cómo
fracasó y cómo logró algo que en
realidad en política pues muchas veces
son dos dos caras de una misma ver allá
podríamos decir yo agradezco a mi actor
como europeo que soy que haya sido capaz
de contribuir decisivamente a que el
proyecto europeo en esta última década
década y media no haya hecho aguas sino
que de momento pues siga adelante